сови братам чи дні сили затужив і
щоб треба кранчик а мої голови з ходу
зчитують ще на диво йшов дворів на полі
щитові забула як наша частка css3
мою ліди сльоза модель чорні стренджа
нашу за вибухами вона сили суп напував його
б ще у мили теж красава 100 уе [ __ ]
на
лазерний громадяни Росії мною прийнято
рішення про проведення спеціальних військових
[музика]
щоб харчуватися
ось це все ось це все ось це все
ось туди ще один типу щось мені
підказує що я [ __ ] не зніму
що для мене я буду ігр інстаграм це
джерело заробітку ви глибоко помиляєтеся
[ __ ] це просто це все життя це душа
[музика]
ну і що стосується вашої питання про те
чи плануємо ми нападати на інші
країни інші країни вано подати не
планують на Україну не нападали б і
і т.д. як дорожче я поставлю прості питання
ви відповідаєте на них чого був українець
на поділі
колегам не відвідає побачити звернуть на
крокує раби будуть риба ми б їх [ __ ]
пиріг вона це звичайно зараз ви ну-ка
дай sky набрати ризи для кленів вирізи
на paypal і очко жим-жим і бань servizi
рослин не люди що подарувати на день
народження
туалетний папір або може бути лист а4
бо все буде коштувати сука як
нирку belle я люблю всіх людей грим 1
ярд настя завірюху врата і я знаю чого їх
причини нас правді [ __ ] то явно
путін придумай о-о-о
путін ти довбоєб про
путін ти нугою о-о-о вся планета чека і
щоб ти здох буде і довгу про
путін ти дугою
о-о-о-о-о-о-о-о
cz прибрати у я йшов window площа битого
cj танку купальник вона була тільки 5
beta ate a dime store
приїхали і доповнила його, бо вся
Україна
я вас усіх тато ряд жалю я ж ти пам'ятай
заражав а ви підлюки слухав і по а нам
прийшли тон наші землі ставок чим не
москалі пітер земля мій гавкаю вам стане
прийшли тон наші землі брутні ні чим не
москали 50 земля мій гавкаю вам треба у нас
підбити і людей розсипте зерна і
дітей у вас же мати у коте сипуха ти
вуса а культурної та жива посилок але час
жива а вам нас with me як прн його ти
булса культурної та жива маса 1 1 а вам
нас світ кпрф а ти що за чорт україна я
був малий але я пам'ятаю і лише почав з одеси
а а потім пішов у стару криму і а ось
хто ти здохнеш не встигнувши дійти до Києва
збирайте їм додому давай сволота будемо
прийду в бій о-о-о
путін ти дугою о-о-о
путін ти блакитний
о-о-о вся планета чека і йшов би ти здох
буде і довгу
путін ти дугою
о-о-о-о-о-о
cz у добрати ще
слідів за раз і вливати працівник
фарба [ __ ] еб твою матір ви
я хочу
мій
весна та
attack росії
і народитися
ви знаєте раз
[музика]
[оплески]
у повному комплекті
мішки з піском
[музика]
злегка продірявлена
новий вигляд
аташе вигляд буває від складу хвороба
такому блідий захищених політ пісні
сасуці по тій повилазили річки стали
малюнку ще зараз пеклі за рахунок сказав а
можна було зачистити мона диза sistar він
такий звільнитися і нашому бардачок у
прийшло сюди міг народитися одеса ​​у них за
зростання радянський апарат 5 таким кору та
старий як пояснити небо над 5 ну хулі
там бояться чесно від путіна, а якщо
чесно тузи трояндами ну і ви бабок [ __ ]
скоро подихати звичайно хочеться куща
собачку в buy але особливою поритися вирішивши
відсвяткувати гостях звичайно хай заходи
потенційно верстат
музикантом та
[музика]
так очевидно
приватизованого